the process involved in transitioning
children's gender is coming under
increased scrutiny as NHS rules that
enable children as young as 12 to start
gender transition treatment before
puberty without their parents support
are finally being reconsidered in
England and Wales currently children
unhappy with their birth gender can
begin hormone suppression treatment
after as few as 3 therapeutic
assessments before moving on to
cross-sex hormones to children can
discuss treatment separately from their
parents and are encouraged to develop
autonomy in decision taking the average
age for these children is 14 now I
support transgender rights but just as
being anti-racist doesn't necessitate
uncritically accepting all anti-racist
ideas ever proposed like quota systems
likewise being pro trans doesn't
necessitate blindly accepting every
single development some topics in life
are simultaneously hard incredibly
sensitive and terribly complicated this
is one of them we would all be advised
to hit pause here for a moment because
we must fully think through all the
consequences involved before we rush
into a quagmire that we don't yet fully
understand see when I found out we were
doing this topic I thought it was
important to get an input a direct input
into this conversation from somebody who
is transfer reached out to a trans woman
an activist called Tara Hewitt and she's
and she told me she doesn't understand
why we would challenge existing legal
principles namely the Gillick competency
principle that children should be able
to make important decisions about
themselves that affect their lives and
in this case we're talking about hormone
special treatments from the age of
negative 12 for example which can be
used in other circumstances yet nobody's
challenging those she believes that this
use of things about safety or competency
is more about people who don't
particularly like the idea of trans
people and not so much about protecting
people now me personally I remember as a
kid I came across there was a boy in my
school who
yes gender expression is necessarily a
definite symbol of this person's going
to be trans but my 11 year old
thought that is a girl in a boy's body
and right now she's fully transitioned
and to be frank she looks stunning if
she had been denied that treatment her
life would be significantly harder right
now and if and to deny people important
medical treatment simply because we're
not sure when they are sure it seems to
be wrong this is how can you be sure
Beth something is important this a 12/14
let me let me read you a statement from
a girl called Kiera Belle she's
currently suing the Tavistock trust and
she transition she says I do not believe
the children and young people can
consent to the use of powerful and
experimental hormone drugs like I did
the treatment needs to change so that it
does not put young people like me on a
torturous on unnecessary path that is
permanent and life-changing now these
this is a young and you know you're
talking about slowing down this process
you know anyone who has urged caution in
recent years on this matter they have
they have been either slated as a
transfer Boran all right bigoted and
because we're told that every young
person knows their own mind it's simply
not true and currently there's a growing
demographic of people who have
transitioned and no one now D
transitioning I know Matt just got a
quote from a girl called Charlie Evans
let me just talk to her and then you can
do the thing she she she was born a girl
transitioned to a boy and then D
transitioned in 2018 and she started a
charity called the D transition advocacy
Network
she says hang on she's been approached
by hundreds of people thirty in her home
city of Newcastle Lu who have gone
through this life-changing surgery and
now bitterly regretted and are gonna
have to to get to revert back this is
where we're playing Russian roulette
with kids like it since you've mentioned
her let's go to John Easley so there I
want to bring you to in as well because
I think there are the point firmly made
there are voices on both sides of this
and that's the point actually I'm making
which is we don't know which way this
can go so here's Charlie Evans it was
only when I looked back at my experience
that I realized sort of the path that I
had been on and how fixated that I felt
therapists and doctors and clinicians
had all a firm agenda they'd all said
yes you are a boy obviously I match the
diagnostic criteria for gender dysphoria
in that I'm not comfortable with the way
women are like meant to act um but
because I don't think that that
necessarily makes me actually a man just
because I feel like I'm not willing now
there's another point I'd like to bring
in here which is one of the
psychologists that used to work at the
Tavistock important NHS Trust where they
specialized in this gender transition
for children and this one particularly
shocks me this psychologist said looking
back there are young people who I now
wouldn't necessarily put on medication
or sign off on medication one of the
reasons I left the service is because I
didn't feel like I could ever say to a
parent that I didn't believe their child
was transgender I thought that if I ever
spoke to a family like this I would
immediately be called transphobic now
what worries me about this is if
professional medical advice is being
with Hill withheld from fear of being
called transphobic that really I think
is a dereliction of duty
let's just hear what the gender identity
development service that Tavistock
comportment NHS Foundation Trust has to
say clinicians at the gender identity
development service have regular
supervision sessions where they can
discuss any concerns including caseload
there are numerous other forums in which
to raise issues and concerns we've
conducted exit interviews with all
departing staff to understand their
motivations and identify any areas of
concern the work is demanding the
pressures of operating in a busy service
facing a high level of unfair criticisms
are intense and their motivations are as
individual as they are for my input my
eye was drawn to the research data that
the team kindly sends us and some
research that Sky News says has put
together which is over the last three
years thirty-five psychologists have
left so that's roughly one a month all
I've I don't know if there's a young
person whose who is I actually believe
in it that there can be people who are
born I totally get that and we must
afford all help and simply I am
concerned though that there could be a
bit of a rush here and for that level of
resignation
it makes people who've left as well they
left because they felt the people and
the clinic weren't being assessed
properly or thoroughly enough I just
like to make a couple of points here and
the first is that speaking with people
who are transitioned
all the parents of people who have
children are going through a process my
impression is that actually it is slow
it is very slow and there is lots of
support networks around it you know
including psychologists counselors and
it's the case of watchful waiting as it
has been described to me to make sure
that the people going through the
process are comfortable with it the
other thing is that there was a study in
2013 from a US psychologist and she
looked at as children who were
transgender or non non-conforming and
it's quite an interesting study because
it we don't really have large datasets
because so much of this is you know
initial stages but it was 85 kids and
they were looking for markers and one of
the things that was striking about
children who did end up transitioning
was that they had a really strong sense
of identity they knew who they were and
what psychologists are saying about this
is that it's the sense of identity that
drives the gender and not the other way
around because I think the the stuff
that happened because you said it's a
very slow watchful process I just read a
case history this week of a girl called
Ruby who said you go in there it's just
that it's almost like they go there's
your hormones that's how you get the
surgery off you go back in reconcile
things to - I can reconcile this I think
what you're addressing is the entire
process maybe yes but the initial stages
of putting children under 16 onto
hormones requires three consultations
and what you may be interested to know
is that this will be actually the first
time that our own in-country guidelines
are being devised when they look at
these standards the NHS up until now we
were using standards that were devised
by an international conference so I
think it is important to just have a
look at this and understand without
parental consent children under 14 if
they go on these blockers and they're
not with the support of their parents
just at least have transparency and
understand how that process is put in
place let me put a word in on the
process again from the gender identity
development service Tavistock and
Portland NHS Foundation Trust which
addresses your point decisions about
physical interventions made in our care
or arrived at after a thorough
exploration process while some of our
patients may decide not to pursue
physical treatment or drop out of
treatment the experience
of regret described here is rarely seen
look I think it's really important that
we hear from somebody who has been
through this process so here's Leo if I
couldn't live my life as a mayor we'll
be on have the body of a male I don't
think I'd be around by the age of twenty
thirty on just don't think I would you
know your gender is a fundamental part
of who you are as a person and it
defines and effects so much so when
that's wrong and when your mind and body
are alienated it it's not something you
can cope with for that amount of time
and it it would just break you down and
leo is exactly why early intervention is
so crucial because if it doesn't happen
his life would be so much harder well
that indicates why it's so important to
have these voices included and we've
heard now from both perspectives
somebody that regretted doing it and
somebody who didn't and that's I think
what I'm saying is let's just understand
what's going on here what are the things
that I think is important in this debate
is that you know we're talking about an
extremely vulnerable group of people who
are already stigmatized and who have
incredibly high levels of attempted
suicide self harm and distress and I
think that it's really important that we
have these conversations in the way not
just that the sake the process of
transitioning but the actual
conversations we have about it should be
responsible and safeguarding of an
already vulnerable community and we've
heard from some trans voices today and
that would help us well actually so on
that note I've got to move on now
whether he's talking about a miraculous
interment or a or being reincarnated on
earth no word in English language is
off-limits when it comes to our
quintessentially British prime minister
his effort effort the switch from
bundling bluster to a flamboyant
elephants leaves many people marveling
and many many more wondering what the
he's talking about which is exactly what
happened in Parliament this week when he
read up his statement on HS to two MPs
fortunately for Boris Johnson he spent
years perfecting his unique style and
delivery to disguise his bluster with an
air of knowledge ability but no such
luck for the poor soul tossed
with delivering the prime minister's
statement in the House of Lords and it
was parliamentary Undersecretary of
State at the Department for Transport
Baroness vir of Norton who ended up
taking 113 cyclists enjoying hundreds of
miles of brand-new separated lanes with
with mini Holland's blooming like so
many tulips cyclists enjoying hundreds
of miles of brand-new separated lanes
with mini Holland's blooming like so
many tulips in towns and cities yes we
must fix the joint between the knee bone
of the fiber and the chin bone and the
ankle bone and yes we must fix the
arthritis in the fingers and the toes
yes we must fix the joint between the
knee bone and the thigh bone and the
shin bone and the ankle bone and yes we
must fix the arthritis in the fingers
and the toes
new generation of cyclists pedal safely
and happily to school and work in tree
dappled sunlight a new generation of
cyclists pedals safely and happily to
school and work in tree dappled sunlight
on their
Berenice me for managing to make it the
whole way through
you are our deadpan delivery of the week